We thought you'd
be talking just about Tiger Woods return.
He is an incredible athlete.
But instead,
golf fans
cannot believe his juvenile joke
when Woods handed a tampon
to a fellow golfer.
And that golfer was Justin Thomas.
Christine, what's your reaction
when you heard what he did and why
as you said that,
Sarah, just a juvenile act.
I mean, Tiger
is a 47 year old father of a girl, dad of
of a girl.
He's a girl. Dad, an athlete's age.
15 year old daughter,
Sam is a soccer player.
And for Tiger to be that girl, dad
and to be nearing 50 years old
and playing the kind of prank
that boys did
maybe in junior high
middle school, high school,
and have long since moved on from.
It was extraordinary.
And it certainly
was not the biggest deal,
Sarah, in the world.
Clearly, it's not the biggest news,
as we all know.
But it is illustrative of a problem
that golf has and really golf alone
in terms of the misogyny
and the sexism in a sport
that is desperately trying
to attract women,
title nine
women, millions of them who are out there
going to play sports
the rest of their lives to play golf.
And for for generations,
the sport had to stop, sign up
Augusta National, no women members
so many other places
I guess to change that in 2012.
But the bottom line is that golf
has been really quite
hostile in many ways
to inviting women to play.
And this just adds to their storyline
the most famous golfer of all doing
something so ridiculous
And then of course
it just blows up because it's Tiger
and he's going to get
that kind of attention
and he knows that he's
going to get that kind of attention.
Yeah I mean he is Tiger Woods
I do want to say I mean,
I know what he's trying to say by handing
the tampon over
because, you know, women bleed
and they still play sport
and they still kick ass.
It doesn't matter
So I don't know what he was trying to say
using that, but I can guess.
But he is apologizing. Well,
I'm going to let him
talk on the other end of it.
Play like a girl. Right.
And girls are frickin awesome.
So he was actually giving him
a compliment, in my view.
But that's just me.
He wrote an opinion column for USA Today.
And in it, you say, while this is by far,
it's far from the biggest issue in sports
these days,
it does play right into a decades
old narrative
that the leaders of golf
are desperately trying to change.
Clearly, with limited success.
What is that Decades-Old narrative?
You talked a little bit about it
at the beginning that they've been trying
to get women into the sport
and yet they're not welcomed
No.
And golf doesn't even realize
how badly it's done.
Basically, Sarah,
the greatest capitalists among us,
many of them are members
of some of the elite golf clubs.
I think we all know who
we're talking about.
It might be someone's grandfather
or the neighbor.
The country club set those those men
mostly in almost all
cases, are the greatest capitalists
that we know.
And for generations,
they have chosen sexism over capitalism.
Hard to believe and one of the more
Mind-Numbing decisions
a business has ever made,
the business of golf.
You want women to join to buy
more golf
shoes and golf clubs
and play more rounds of golf.
And yet golf pushed away
its growth
industry for,
as I said, four generations now.
It was trying to catch up
And I do give credit to Augusta National.
They have the women's amateur now,
but that is it.
That's absolutely
telling people women can play golf.
And again,
while
the tampon gate, as we could call
it, is not the biggest thing going on.
And obviously, we're even laughing.
And Tiger's non-apology was ridiculous.
Just own up to it and say you're sorry.
But it does
illustrate that same exact point
that, you know,
why would a 22 year old great athlete
who is coming out of college
and could play any sport
and there is, you know,
hundreds of sports
you could be playing are or leagues
you could be in
why would you choose a sport with
that has a dude who's
given some guy a tampon
and that's the problem for golf.